d'abord mauvaise gestion des faïences
enchaînement de dysfonctionnements dans
le rapport remis aujourd'hui les
sénateurs et riz la gestion du fiasco du
stade de france pas gérald darmanin et
le préfet l'allemand jonathan du prix y
est
les sénateurs ne passe pas par quatre
chemins le fiasco de la finale de la
ligue des champions est due à un
enchaînement de dysfonctionnement des
défaillances des autorités françaises
dans dans l'exécution que dans la
préparation de cet événement sportif
majeur c'est un enchaînement de
dysfonctionnements qui se sont produits
dans un cadre administratif
et décisionnaires assez flou dans lequel
finalement personne ne s'est vraiment
senti responsable ces dysfonctionnements
ils ont eu lieu à toutes les étapes de
de cet événement c'est à dire bien sûr
pendant l'exécution mais aussi en amont
dans la préparation il ya eu des
défaillances lors de la préparation et
après l'événement avec là aussi une
série de dysfonctionnements qui n'aurait
pas dû se produire les parlementaires
ont aussi vivement dénoncé les
déclarations du ministre de l'intérieur
au lendemain des incidents gérald
darmanin avait fait porter la
responsabilité de cet échec aux anglais
dénonçant 35 mille supporters munis de
faux billets or les sénateurs parle de
2006 en faux billets comme l'uefa pour
les sénateurs gérald darmanin n'a donc
pas dit la vérité d'où cette petite
pique adressée aux ministres par
françois noël buffet si la vérité avait
été dite tout de suite
immédiatement on ne serait pas là deux
mois après à se retrouver à faire un
rapport est un mythe le système soit été
constatés et les choses auraient été
réglées peut-être rapidement tous les
cas on l'espère outre ces points les
sénateurs préconisent une quinzaine de
mesures pour tirer les leçons de ce
ratage parmi elles définir une doctrine
sur l' usage des gaz lacrymogènes
imposer aux opérateurs des enceintes
sportives de conserver les images de
vidéosurveillance ou encore rendre
obligatoire le recours au billet un
fal'cie fiable des recommandations ayant
un écho tout particulier à deux ans des
jeux olympiques de paris
trois grands thèmes dans notre débats
d'actu politique ce fiasco du stade de
france le rejet du projet de loi
sanitaire en tout cas retoqué certains
articles à l'assemblée puis la plainte
d'associations anti homophobie après les
propos de caroline cayeux la ministre
des collectivités territoriales vous
présente mes invités car chartier
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
et essayiste alexia gère mon bonjour
bienvenue à vous aussi président du
cercle de réflexion france audacieuse
jean daniel lévy bienvenue jean daniel
directeur délégué de l'institut harris
interactive france et matthieu
croissandeau éditorialiste politique
heureux de vous retrouver cette semaine
puisque vous n'étiez pas là
exceptionnellement lundi ce rapport
sénatorial claire chartier bon c'est
d'abord une pierre dans le jardin humide
de l'intérieur on peut dire ça aussi
simplement oui je pense que ça met bien
en lumière en fait le problème de la
parole politique
il est évident au vu de ces conclusions
dont on avait quand même déjà en partie
connaissance que effectivement ces
événements sont répondre à toute une
série de dysfonctionnements hors bons
gérald darmanin on s'est tous est
vraiment très vite sorti sur la place
publique en avec des assertions en fait
qui ne correspondait pas à la situation
et en fait ça répond vraiment je pense
ça correspond vraiment à une difficulté
aujourd'hui la parole politique prendre
autant de libertés avec le réel en
croyant de ce fait finalement renforcé
l'autorité de l'état dévier le tir qui
arrive sur le gouvernement pour voilà en
tenant ce genre de propos c'est en fait
aboutir à exactement l'effet inverse
recherché et on reproduit la gérald
darmanin état assez coutumier du fait on
reproduit la à mécanisme qui aujourd'hui
est me semble-t-il est un mécanisme qui
n'est plus vraiment toléré par les gens
et d'ailleurs il ya eu cette phrase une
le ministre n'a pas dit la vérité on
peut plus se satisfaire de ce genre de
réponse qui en plus répondait à un
contexte électoral puisqu'on était en
législatives certains d'ailleurs on
considérer que ça avait porté préjudice
à la majorité présidentielle parce qu'on
a bien vu la divergence en fait donc on
est là vraiment sur un mécanisme
politique tactique à mon avis est
totalement éculés et que gérald darmanin
incarne assez facilement effectivement
on
avec s'affirmant au point de départ
c'est les propos du ministre de
l'intérieur au soir du 28 mai alors on
va être précis a dit effectivement à
pales de 35 mille supporters de
liverpool sans billet ou avec des
billets falsifiés c'est ça la formule
exacte soit il est mal informé ce qui
est possible dans l'est dans les minutes
ou dans les heures qui suivent soit et
là ça pose la question de du fait de
continuer d'être sur cette ligne dans
les jours qui suivent soit effectivement
il ment aux français mais si on déroule
le fil c'est ça qui serait aussi
intéressant c'est à dire d'avoir la
claire visibilité sur ce qui s'est passé
la réaction politique a été très rapide
trop rapide certainement puisque c'était
dans l'instant pour essayer de dévier le
tir comme vous avez dit dans un contexte
électoral ou sur le terrain on a bien vu
que ça avait évidemment pesé et puis
pardon vous interromps mais moi je pense
aussi que c'est parce que le la grille
de lecture elle était datée oui ils sont
arrivés sur cette soirée avec une grille
de lecture qui était la grille de
lecture colligan isme
donc en fait il ya eu un prisme qui a
été pris qui était vraiment la question
des des billets du loup canis mais tu
sais alors qu'on voit très bien dans le
rapport
du sénat qui avait il y avait quand même
une préfiguration avec le rapport
cadeaux d'ailleurs où il y avait quand
même certaines choses qui apparaissait
déjà on voit très bien que c'est à la
fois bon préparation certes mais aussi
manque de
2,2 de transversalité entre les services
parce que ça ça compte aussi énormément
c'est que si chacun est dans son silo
c'est sûr que ça peut pas fonctionner et
les effets en terme de visibilité ça a
était délétère aussi pour la capacité de
la france à accueillir des événements
sportifs de grande envergure et quand on
regarde dans le détail ce qui a été dit
là aujourd'hui lors de la conférence de
presse sur le rapport du sénat on voit
notamment que sur la partie en fait à
vouloir trop bien faire il avait c'est
là où il ya eu un loupé notamment sur
les opérations de filtrage à la sortie
du rer on sait que ça a été le démarrage
en fait des défaillances le préparer le
pré filtrage parce qu'en fait ils ont
voulu à la fois adapté des questions
antiterroriste avec un filtrage sur les
billets sur ceux qui avaient les billets
ou pas de billet donc évidemment on voit
bien que la au lieu de rester chacun
dans son créneau c'est une défaillance
de pluie chez jean daniel lévy bhl mais
claire chartier elle a évoqué mais quel
impact est on est on est le 28 mai à
deux semaines du tout petit peu plus du
premier tour des législatives est ce qu
on a pu mesurer
l'impact de ce fiasco dans l'opinion
c'est peut être dans les votes déjà en
fait dès ce qui est intéressant c'est
que d'une manière générale en fait le
gouvernement n'est pas toujours qualifié
comme étant d'un point de vue d'opinion
extrêmement bon sur la question et
sécurité et quand vous regardez les
électeurs d'un point de vue global ils
vont considérer que ceux qui sont
préoccupés par la question de sécurité
vont tourner d'un côté vers les
candidats aient l'air est évidemment
vers les candidats du rassemblement
national d'oak en marche ensemble n'est
pas forcément la force politique qui
apparaît comme étant celle qui va être
qualifié spontanément la part des
individus comme capable de pouvoir
garantir l'autorité l'état en toutes
circonstances qu'on peut ajouter à cela
remet alors quand vous regardez la cote
de confiance à l'égard de gérald
darmanin n'a jamais été très élevé et
quand vous la comparez à d'autres
ministre de l'intérieur par le passé
c'est pas en fait celui qui peut
incarner ou par nature l'autorité et la
manière de pouvoir faire en sorte que
l'ordre républicain soit assurée dans
notre de notre territoire national d'oak
ya eu effectivement n'ont pas forcément
un départ des lecteurs qui avaient
envisagé initialement de beauté pour
emmanuel macron ou ses candidats aux
élections initiative et qui sont dignes
fils ne va pas le faire mais plutôt
peut-être un renforcement d'autres
forces politiques à savoir les nerfs
d'un côté et également
le ratio national de l'autre ce qui est
intéressant également dans cette
séquence c'est que ça s'est passé le
samedi mais le dimanche en fait il ya eu
un match qui s'est passé à geoffroy
guichard et tient à saint-etienne avec
des actes de violence dans le stade qui
sont je crois sans commune mesure avec
ce à quoi on a pu assister la veille
avec des personnes qui ont quand même
pris des supporters des mortiers et
qu'on tirait sur le staff l'encadrement
voire même l'équipe de saint-etienne
mécontent du résultat ce moment là est
passée quasiment inaperçue et d'un point
de vue d'opinion en dépit de la violence
qui est une comme d'une tout autre
nature parce que comme des personnes qui
ont réussi à entrer dans 16 états ce que
l'on trouve intéressant c'est que
derrière ce qui s'est passé dans
l'affrontement liverpool pas du déroulé
du match liverpool le real c'est que
c'est également l'image de la france au
niveau international qui étaient pour
partie touchée et c'est pas uniquement
mais sinon c'est ça qui insistent dans
l'opinion quoi voilà donc c'est pas
uniquement la question la sécurité qui a
été au centre du regard qui a été porté
à l'issue de ses prestations mais c'est
au final quelle image attend de la
france au niveau international quelles
vont être les déroulée et on l'a entendu
tout à l'heure dans le temps le
reportage quelles conséquences cela
peut-il avoir pour les jo et puis après
potentiellement pour l'attractivité de
la france alors on peut rappeler que la
france a déjà organisé beaucoup de
grands événements sportifs et les a très
bien organisé donc on peut espérer qu'on
soit à la hauteur dit d'ici deux ans je
propose d'écouter est ce que gérald
darmanin qui était au sénat cet après
midi pour les questions au gouvernement
a répondu aux critiques
ne suivront les recommandations du sénat
ces recommandations qui sont finalement
en trois parties la première sur la
billettique avec la ministre des sports
à la ma première ministre nous a demandé
d'appliquer notamment auprès des
organisateurs et auprès de nos propres
organisations sportives ces billets 1
fasse siffler à b et toutes les
recommandations que vous évoquez en
termes d'ordre public c'est un point
très important de votre passage de votre
rapport à la fois pour passer d'un
moment on la police doit être moins
tournée vers l'hooliganisme mais plus
sur les mouvements de foule et notamment
sur la protection de nos concitoyens
et puis le troisième sujet c'est
évidemment le sujet de la délinquance
puisque vous avez évoqué évidemment dans
notre rapport
un constat qui était réelle puisque ce
soir là je reprends vos mots monsieur le
président de la commission non seulement
il ya eu des dysfonctionnements mais des
erreurs de préparation dont la
préfecture de police miss à l'intérieur
et les mises intérieur de tirer de
conséquences pour conclure sur cette
première séquence pierre chartier vous
diriez quoi il fait profil bas
aujourd'hui voile darmana oui assez en
phase ont quand même reconnaître qu'il
est allé un peu vite en besogne jusqu'à
effectivement déclenché l'ire des
autorités britanniques pour rebondir qui
a quand même les autorités au retail
pour demander une enquête quand même
donc ce n'est pas rien à aller jusque là
je pense qu'effectivement comme ça coché
toutes les cases
tout c'est toutes ces thématiques
attisées par l'opposition et notamment
celle du rn je pense que ça peut
expliquer aussi une forme de
précipitation de gérald darmanin qui
s'est déroulé là on est sur la
thématique sécurité image internationale
effectivement fonds sont pour rassurer
tout le monde et qu'on est cons et qu'on
a là encore mais non je pense pas je
pense qu'il le faire moi je nomme je ne
le comprends pas comment un véritable
mea culpa il ne dit pas je suis allé un
peu vite dans l'analyse il avait fait
jeu mais moi j'ai pris un peu de temps
vous l'avez vous vécu les emmenons mais
ce qui permet de sortir par le haut là
pour tout le monde sait qu'il ya des
recommandations qui sont évidemment très
carrée qui permettent de dire évidemment
on va aller on va les mettre en place au
passage quoi tout le monde peut quand
même être étonné du fait qu'ils aient
pas de billetterie électronique d'ores
et déjà mises en place
enfin electronica falsifiable au stade
de france pour des événements oui mais
il y en avait mais que le club coule qui
a refusé car ça c'était en partie la
responsabilité de l'uefa
a édité des billets papier poney pour
des événements de ce type là c'est ça
paraît quand même être de bonnes je
pense que si a beaucoup choqué aussi
c'est que des gens des familles dd se
fassent effectivement reçoit du des
lames particules comme ça 5 mai qui se
prennent des gaz dans la matinée en face
à c'est vrai que là il ya un problème et
un déficit dans nous dit rien sur la
grille de lecture initiale à willy kanis
les plantes
les supporters de familles des gens qui
n'ont vraiment absolument pas de
comportement ça je pense que ça a
beaucoup choqué l'opinion publique on va
ouvrir et d'ailleurs ça va nous perdre
cela envoie le sénat l'avait finalement
avec ses propositions et on va continuer
d' évoquer ce thème là dans cet
équilibre ce nouvel équilibre
parlementaire puisque l'actuelle
politique de ce mercredi c'est aussi ce
projet de loi sanitaire présenté à
l'assemblée hier mathieu premier revers
il suit par le gouvernement puisque
l'assemblée a sévèrement amputé le texte
oui c'est le revers d'hier est un
avertissement pour les abbés de bornes
et pour le camp présidentiel
parce qu'on assistait en live un peu à
la bande annonce de ce que pourrait être
la législature si jamais elle dure cinq
ans avoir été mis en minorité sur le
premier texte de la législature c'est
d'abord un échec d'organisation au cas
où ils avaient paralysé bas ne disposer
que d'une majorité relative et ben ça
impose au gouvernement il ya ceux qui le
soutiennent une anticipation une
discipline de fer et hier il a manqué
des députés renaissance des députés aux
horizons pour pour voter dans la
mystique certains ont dû interrompre les
travaux en commissions et descendre à
toute vitesse en renfort dans
l'assemblée tous les votes se prépare
dans une situation pareille et là
manifestement sonne ça n'a pas été
ensuite leur verdière il illustre un
échec de méthode parce qu'on soutient il
avait deux bornes appelé plusieurs fois
au compromis est l'affiché d'une
certaine façon une intention faut
désormais que ça se traduise dans les
faits et ce travail il doit se faire en
amont c'est à dire en commission ça a
été le cas sur le calendrier des mesures
c'était prévu jusqu'à mars finalement
ils ont accepté le gouvernement de
réduire jusqu'à jusqu'à janvier mais le
reste du texte aurait dû faire l'objet
d'un subtil travail de déminage en
apportant ici des précisions qu'il
manquait on l'a vu parce que parfois
c'est la rédaction du texte étaient
incriminés hier dans les débats ou là
les concessions qu'il fallait parce
qu'en fait si on veut bâtir un compromis
il faut quand même donner un peu du sien
et prendre le temps alors là c'est un
texte en urgence mais ça n'a pas été
fait et puis le revers d'hier il traduit
en ferait une erreur d'appréciation en
mieux avec le camp présidentiel a
sous-estimé la volonté de marquer le
coup l'opposition peut-être parce qu'il
s'agissait à ses yeux que d'un texte qui
prévoyait de prolonger des outils
sanitaire désormais bien connues et non
pas d'un texte politique de réformes
imaginer ce que ça aurait été ou un
texte d'une réforme sur des questions
nationales des choses comme ça et il a
surestimé al'inverse l'étanchéité des
groupes qui composent l'opposition avec
notamment l'abstention du r'n sur la
motion de censure sa volonté d'afficher
une opposition constructive ne pas mêler
ses voix à celles de la nuit baisse en
fait c'était qu'une mystification et le
rnd qui aujourd'hui
position d'arbitré oui parce que quoi
qu'ils fassent on retrouvera partout des
traces de son adn qu'ils s'abstiennent
au bénéfice d'un texte gouvernemental ou
a fortiori qu'ils votent pour et on
accusera aussitôt elisabeth bornes de
composer avec l'extrême droite ils
votent contre la gauche et en reprochera
aussitôt à la nuque baisse une
dangereuse année dans ces circonstances
quand ce n'est pas une collision des
extrêmes c'est dire la difficulté qui
attend le camp présidentiel aux caïmans
beaucoup voient mais encore plus si
comme le groupe et avec born elle ne va
pas chercher les oies du rnb le rapport
enfin l'on trouve beaucoup c'est à dire
aussi la difficulté qui attend la gauche
parce que celle ci pourra plus très
longtemps joué double jeu en versant des
larmes de crocodile sur le front
républicain tout en additionnant quand
ça les arrange ses voix à celles du
parti de marine le pen lan ip s'y
perdrait enfin il prendrait le risque
d'y perdre à la fois son âme et son
unité et à ce titre est un fait hier qui
a pas tellement été soulignée c'est que
le groupe ps a brillé par son absence
quand il s'est agi de voter sans doute
parce que c'est sur ce sujet les
socialistes rappelons le qui était un
partisan de l'obligation vaccinale
se sentait plus proche de leurs
adversaires du gouvernement que de leurs
alliés de l'ani ps oui c'est grand écart
ne pourront pas durer très très
longtemps merci mathieu on va revenir
évidemment au groupe ps mais peut-être
d'abord avec serge herman avertissement
pour elisabeth bord mais ce que vous le
recevez comme ça aussi
ça montre toute la difficulté
qui s'annonce dans cette mandature
législatives évidemment après cc c'est
très bien résumé par matthieu
croissandeau tout est dit à beaucoup de
choses
cheville c'est comme ça qu'on l'a
construit et puis ensuite on les reprend
exactement
parce que c'est une quadrature du cercle
qui est difficile pour chaque groupe en
réalité avec
l'idée qui serait une fabuleuse idée si
on était capable d'arriver au bout le
compromis ce serait quelque chose qui
d'abord nous habitue ray ce qui se passe
aussi à l'échelon européen donc c'est
très loin de notre culture et c'est vrai
qu'on arriverait à on pourrait arriver à
construire des textes plus solide à ce
moment-là mieux mieux mieux reconnus
mais on en est très loin mais non mais
je finis ma phrase et on en est très
loin parce que ce que l'on voit c'est
que pour faire un compromis c'est comme
une négociation contractuelle il faut de
l'envié de chaque parent de la raison et
puis des gestes il n'y a pas que des
gestes à avoir il y a d'abord toujours
de la pédagogie parce qu'on ne peut pas
arriver à faire bouger quelqu'un sur ses
positions si on ne comprend pas d'où on
vient donc il ya énormément de pédagogie
ya du travail en préparation vous l'avez
très bien dit qui peut être manque parce
que là c'était un texte en urgence donc
on voit bien qu'il y aura des des
cadrages et décalages à effectuer et
puis il ya des concessions et pour finir
pas monopoliser la parole mais pour
finir et c'est là où l'expérience de
l'avocat ressort aussi mais un mot peut
tout changer donc quand vous avez des
amendements qui sont proposés là en
l'occurrence c'était une position sur
suppression pas suppression mais vous
imaginez ce que ça va être quand on va
être à négocier si ça n'a pas été fait
en amont ou pas suffisamment fait en
amont
mot-à-mot des modifications qui peuvent
tout changer sur des sur des articles de
loi avec un rôle du sénat qui évidemment
va venir
on va très vite et si on est un peu plus
tard au rôle du sénat jean d'y amener le
dévisser la question de la méthode
reprend effectivement l'un des aspects
de
de l'édito de mathieu
pour l'instant et on n'a pas eu une
méthode de co-construction alors
peut-être de la part d oppression mais
aussi et d'abord de la part du
gouvernement oui enfin pour
co-construire il faut être dur un sessad
est bien d'accord ou plus mais pour
qu'elle vote deux types d'acteurs ceux
qui rédigent et ceux qui participent
je suis pas persuadé que jusqu'à présent
en fait du côté de la nuque d'un côté
enfin en tout cas pour la partie la plus
à gauche de la lune et du côté du racing
en national de l'autre sur des sujets
qui sont assurés qui apparaissent alors
j'ai comme étant profondément
emblématique il ya une vraie volonté de
co-construction de là pour le coup vous
avez parlé de pédagogie vous avez parlé
d' échanges etc je suis pas persuadé que
même après de nombreuses moment des deux
d'interaction il y aurait forcément eu
une mobilisation différentes de leur
part et peut-être que les visages qui
sert à rien de temps
c'est pour ça que je prendrai deux
exemples il y aura effectivement la
question à l'heure et puis une question
basique c'est que qui est présent
physiquement à l'assemblée nationale au
moment où le vote était un ami déjà lors
de la précédente législature il est
arrivé qu avec un groupe bien plus
important de la majorité soit mise en
minorité et donc en fait il ne serait ce
qu une question de pratique politique
presque politicienne au sens noble du
terme de faire en sorte qu' il puisse y
avoir au moment du vote suffisamment de
personnes qui soient présentes pour
pouvoir éviter en fait est qu'il puisse
y avoir un coup d'éclat comme celui qui
s'est effectuée hier alors on peut se
rappeler que c'est quand même un article
parmi plusieurs
koné à la première lecture donc ça va
aller au sénat est normalement survenir
à l'international donc c'est pas non
plus la loi qui a complètement été
invalidés ou en tout cas à voter cette
manière donc mais mais c'est un premier
gros avertissement déjà à l'égard de
l'écu tiff non seulement sur la méthode
à l'égard de ceux qui ont des velléités
de pouvoir effectivement co construire
et également sur comment on fait
concrètement aujourd'hui pour obtenir
abbott et faire en sorte que la salle
soit pleine des lecteurs qui sont sur la
même ligne que le gouvernement sur le
fond pierre chartier
heurtaux qu'est cet article sur le pass
sanitaires aux frontières comment les
oppositions la aggloméré peuvent
l'assumer face à leurs aînés en effet ce
qu'il ya un peu sur prononce que cette
thématique de passes sanitaires elle est
quand même très emblématiques comme vous
le soulignez et femmes franchement elle
a été au coeur de toutes les
controverses de ces derniers mois donc
considérer que c'est un texte comme ça
comme semble enfin c'est peut-être ce
qui a été le cas pour certains députés
de la majorité qui sont pas mieux c'est
quand même déjà très étonnant
indépendamment de la méthode qu'il a on
peut peut-être se dire que parce que
faute de finalement d'habitude il faut
un apprentissage et que je dirais que
bola on peut leur laisser le temps dans
la préparation des textes mais c'est
vrai que c'est intéressant là déjà de
voir car en fait il ya une
sous-évaluation sous-estimation de
l'enjeu ce qui pose un petit problème
sur le fond je trouve que ça pose la
question qui va nous occuper les années
qui viennent c'est à dire de la place
des 89 députés et rennes enfin mathieu
l'a évoqué dans ce parlement une place
tout à fait inédite et qui a beaucoup de
conséquences en fait évidemment plus du
tout considéré que c'était un parti hors
champ dès l'instant où bon beaucoup de
citoyens français ont élu des députés rn
qu'ils ont des deux vice-présidents et
c'est donc ça c'est certain
de l'autre c'est quand même à partie par
don de le rappeler mais qui avait dans
son programme présidentiel une dimension
celle de la de la priorité nationale qui
va à l'encontre de notre vision
historique de la démocratie qui est
fondée sur l'humanisme est et le
libéralisme donc il ya quand même ça qui
reste vrai je viens dans l'eure et on a
donc un parti elle est fille qui d'un
côté reprochera viala du ps qui
reprochait à la majorité d'avoir voté
enfin d'avoir favorisé finalement
l'élection de ses vice-présidents et
rennes et qui m'attend se retrouve du
côté du rn unis dans une même
détestation on peut le supposer baude
aurait quand même des manuels macron il
était confronté à un dilemme ils ont
tranché ce dilemme c'était quoi le pass
sanitaires beaucoup d'électeurs de l efi
était absolument contre il ya une
convergence dessus avec beaucoup
d'électeurs tué rennes mêlant par l'apa
center aux frontières dira tout ces
temps d écouter ce qu'il dit c'est quand
même aussi parce sanitaires moi oui mais
là on est dans un raccourci
mais bien rhône et dans toute la gestion
qu vite vous faire tenir compte
de tout le temps à des paradoxes moi
j'en mets ma main au feu que oui on donc
ce cynisme au sein des banques alors
voilà disons paradoxe mais d'un côté il
y avait ça et de l'autre côté en effet
elle est fille est donc ce parti qui
représente ce que je viens de dire ils
ont très vite tranché le dilemme hier
que la hier ils ont tranché les mêmes
ils se sont mis de côté ils ont voté de
la même manière se sont pas une
nouveauté mais ils ont voté la même
manière qu à rennes et en ce en se
réjouissant parce qu'on n'a pas vu les
images mais était député reynès et des
poutrelles et si on peut les on peut les
montrer en illustration des propos de
clash quartier pour y aller
applaudissements commun on va dire de
dieu rien n'est venu je trouve que ça
veut dire comme dirait l'autre ça veut
dire beaucoup c'est dire que ça ça
renvoie quand même à la vision que nous
voulons que nous avons de la démocratie
je ne veux pas dire que le fn n'est pas
un parti démocratique mais simplement je
pense qu'on est en train d'évoluer mais
en fait beaucoup trop tôt pour savoir ce
que ça va donner mais dans notre
conception de la démocratie de la parce
que il ya effectivement des démocraties
qui peut être pardon je vais pas donc je
me laissais je fais pas occupé
l'appareil content mais je pense que
l'ange une émission on prend le temps
d'expliquer dans le calaisis où il est
assez profond au travers de ce vote
voilà il ouvre un chemin et c'est pour
ça qu'il est très intéressant à analyser
mathieu est ensuite allé d'une chose
pour compléter ce que vous venez de dire
je pense qu'ils ont tranché avant ils
ont même tranchée au moins du dépôt de
la motion de censure où il ya eu des
appels non dissimulée de députés et les
filles dans dix ans au rnb pourquoi vous
ne votez pas avec nous cette motion de
censure donc déjà dans leur tête
l'opposition emmanuel macron la
délégitimation du pouvoir sortie disions
mal sorti des jantes peut-être mais
sortie des urnes tout de même est arrivé
en tête aux élections législatives pour
me le rappeler est bien et ça vaut pour
eux blanc seing pour nous aider alors on
va dire qu'ils vont s'allier sur le fond
ça serait faux même s'il ya une chose
qui les réunit je pense dans cette
polémique sur le passe sanitaires c'est
qu'on trouve parmi les sympathisants et
les électeurs du fn et parmi les
sympathisants et les électeurs de l'efi
des gens qui considèrent que nous sommes
en dictature que l'on vire dans un
régime liberticide et donc cette espèce
de deux champs de valeur qui se rejoint
sur cette question là au-delà de ça ils
partagent pas grand chose mais on a vu
qu'ils sont prêts de façon cynique ou
pragmatique selon quel point de vue on
se place à nouer des alliances de
circonstance sans eau sans aucune sans
aucune vergogne anesthésiant à moi je
n'ai jamais vu de ma vie je cherche
depuis ce matin de moment où
l'extrême droite et la gauche ce soir et
jouer ensemble d'une mesure d'une idée
d'une
mais d'un événement alexa gérons qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire c'est quand ces
images qu'on vient de voir deux
réflexions complémentaires pour rebondir
par rapport au cynisme ça veut dire
qu'effectivement on va avoir un cynisme
politique auquel vont participer
également le rn qui pourtant veut
s'acheter des
les vertus une voilà une respectabilité
et puis la nuit baisse sur
j'utilise au maximum et c'est évidemment
le droit mais les capacités que qu'ils
ont en siégeant à l'assemblée nationale
pour faire des alliances au gré deuxième
réflexion ça veut dire que ça va être
extrêmement illisible pour les
électorats de chacun parce que
effectivement dire avoir un discours sur
les frontières tout au long d'un d'un
programme et puis quand on a la voix
porte unités de faire un filtrage pour
la mise en place d'un pass sanitaire
juste sur autre chose mais mais on voit
très bien que en termes d'explication
par rapport à son propre électorat c'est
illisible et puis troisième conséquence
également c'est que ça va être
extrêmement difficile
pas que pour les analystes et les
éditorialistes
mais ça va être extrêmement difficile
pour l'exécutif de prévoir de quelle
façon vont se faire ou non les majorités
puisque par nature il n'y a pas de
colonne vertébrale lisible à ce stade là
ça va peut-être venir on ne sait pas
vous positionner avec un grand absent
quand même avec un rôle aussi bien sur
le rn c'est évident mais les l air les
élèves il faut quand même que l'on
puisse avoir une visibilité du
positionnement des élèves et aujourd'hui
je trouve objectivement que c'est assez
compliqué à pouvoir comprendre où ils
vont se trouver parce que là sur le pass
sanitaires c'est aussi c'est aussi
étonnant de voir l'ex qui étaient
présents du groupe et l'air à
l'assemblée a justifié
vote en disant qu'il y avait pas eu de
l'arrogance du gouvernement pas de
co-construction pas de proposition et de
vraies discussions autour du sur le fond
du projet j'en ai les vignes je voudrais
qu'on se concentre un peu sur le
rassemblement national est effectivement
la stratégie républicaine de marine le
pen depuis plusieurs semaines
et la décision de mettre en minorité le
gouvernement sur cet article de lala du
projet de loi sanitaire hier est ce que
c'est contradictoire ou pas c'est leur
en même temps à eux oui mais c'est fait
et une bannière de pouvoir indiquer
qu'il cherche vraiment à être
responsable et à pouvoir montrer ne
serait ce que physiquement en fait on
l'a vu en fait dans la manière dont ils
soient entrées dans les tweets se
présente au sein de hausse à
l'international une forme de
respectabilité de réflexion sur le moyen
et sur le long terme mais ce qui
n'empêche pas par moment de dire nous
avons également des victoires politiques
cette victoire politique est une
histoire on cherche à mettre un peu en
tension le gouvernement et le président
m'appliquer puis également la majorité
en tous cas ceux qui sont issus la
majorité présidentielle il ya un peu
comme dans le sport aux cimes des
intimidations qui peuvent être les
intimidations très match et c'est
peut-être un peu ça qui s'est joué hier
et même quand vous parlez aujourd'hui
avec des députés de proches de la
majorité présidentielle ils disent on
sent quand même beaucoup moins fort que
par le passé même quand on applaudit et
bien le fait qu'on est à peu de choses
près 100 députés de moins que ce qu'on
avait eu au début la précédente
législature eh ben on le sent et cantons
sans glisser à l'oreille
grenier fortement à droite ou à gauche
et même quand elle isabelle borne en
fêtes a tenu son discours de politique
générale où ces déclarations petit
général comme ça arrive également la
réaction de la scène nationale est pas
exactement la même que celle qui a
existé par le passé et malgré tout ces
impacts psychologiques ça fonctionne pas
ça ça oeuvre et donc ça ça crée aussi
une forme de deux de tension à l'égard
aujourd'hui du gouvernement et des
députés qui sont présents aux séances
mettre un coup de nouveaux élus oui il
ya
quasiment plus de personnes de plus de
députés qu'on est ministre
vous avez pour assemblée nationale vous
en avez
quasiment que je crois qu'ils ont dévoré
chez les républicains
vous en avez pas chez les insoumis et
vous en avez un petit peu en marche les
eric woerth et des ministres arabes et
qui était anciennement républicain ça
changera quelque chose dans une
composition d'un hémicycle en tout cas
dans l'animation des groupes parce que
quand on n'a jamais été et puis il n'ya
pas deux il n'ya pas non plus de maires
de grandes villes puisque depuis la
suppression du cumul des mandats il ya
plus de présidents d'exécutifs locaux
donc il ya peu de gens qui ont géré ya
peu de gens qui ont gouverné que ce cas
quelle que soit l'échelle et ça ça va
aussi donner c'est une culture qui va
être absente des groupes qui sont plus
dans l'opposition qu'elle soit vraiment
où qu'elle soit constructive mais dans
la revendication mais pas dans l'idée
que peut-être on est on sera aux
affaires dans cinq ans et pour mémoire
je me souviens j'avais été dix ans
pourrait dire l'un où j'avais été il ya
cinq ans pourrait dire un autre des gens
attention on peut pas promettre
n'importe quoi parce que le jeu on est
au mans je pensais bien qu'on a quand
même plus le choix mais ça toute cette
pâte la disparue 2006 alors cette
culture là elle existe au sénat
évidemment et c'est l'heure de quentin
calmet bonsoir quentin fouine ou rose
nous rejoindre puisque c'est aujourd'hui
les premières questions d'actualité au
gouvernement au sénat avec elisabeth ben
évidemment plusieurs ministres comment
ça s'est déroulé comment s'est passé cet
événement et ça que ça a confirmé ce
qu'on avait un peu senti la semaine
dernière et 10 autres bornes a besoin du
sénat à face à la fragilité de cette et
bien situation ex majorité relative à
l'assemblée nationale qu'on vient de
l'évoquer sur ce plateau donc hier après
le vote contre l'article 2 la première
ministre a tweeté tard dans la nuit il
fera qu'il était 1h50 du matin l'heure
est grave en s'alliant pour voter contre
les mesures de protection des français
face au co vidait les filles les r et le
r n empêche tout contrôle aux frontières
face au virus passe et l'incrédulité sur
ce vote je me battrai pour que l'esprit
de responsabilité
l'emportent au sénat alors ça que la
semaine dernière thomas on avait entendu
une petite musique comme ça alors de la
déclaration de politique générale de la
première ministre c'était mercredi soir
au sénat avec toute une partie de son
discours à la première moitié où elle
faisait comme ça des déclarations
d'amour c'est une expression qui avait
été employé par des sénateurs a l'air le
lendemain et d'un convoi que et bien
effectivement il veut qu construire avec
le sénat fasse aussi à cette turbulence
à la soie nationale sauf que eh bien ça
s'annonce compliqué thomas on peut le
dire ce tweet de la première ministre a
été mal vécue par les principaux
intéressés écoutez philippe à notre
micro il a été rapportée on peut le dire
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire de
tous les projets de loi sanitaire pour
écoute si c'est une pression elle peut
s'en dispenser nous n'avons pas attendu
pour montrer notre sens des
responsabilités sommet vous que nous
avons obtenu des accords en commission
mixte paritaire sur nos amendements dans
78% des lois veut dire que ces lois ne
sont pas exactement celle qu'on aurait
voulu mais au moins nous avons obtenu
que nos amendements soient pris en
compte ce qui fait que tout le mois
elles ont été moins mauvaises que si
elle sénat n'était pas intervenue et
parfois elles ont même été améliorée
donc notre travail c'est ça notre sens
des responsabilités l'avons démontré et
nous n'avons pas de leçons à recevoir
dans ce domaine quant à l'article 2 vous
savez un article 1 qui revient sur le
post anita à la frontière et qui a sauté
à l'assemblée nationale et hier soir la
droite entend bien le rétablir au sénat
mais avec son écriture forcément celle
voulue par les amis de bornes écoutez
bruno retailleau chef de file des verts
au sénat nous ne rétablirons pas le
texte tel que il a été rejeté hier à
l'assemblée nationale nous allons
travailler sur un autre texte pour
clarifier les choses sur le principe je
pense que il faut pouvoir se garantir si
jamais demain dans un autre pays loin de
la france il y avait une nouvelle
mutation qui s'avérait dangereuse faut
évidemment être capable de protéger les
frontières j'ai suffisamment reproché à
hemel macron d'enfermer les français en
même temps qu'il ouvrait toutes grandes
des frontières
pour ne pas en tirer les conséquences
mais ça ne sera certainement pas le
texte identique qui était repoussé hier
à l'assemblée un dernier mot thomas sur
l'ambiance en séance effectuée ce qu'on
a vu ça depuis la tribune de presse dans
l'hémicycle tant qu'on a entendu à
plusieurs reprises pendant cette séance
de questions d'actualité et bien le
gouvernement faire amende honorable se
montrer à l'écouté des sénateurs sur les
difficultés des collectivités locales
sur la demande de la gauche de renforcer
le droit à l'ivg et g sur les remarques
liées à ces incidents autour du stade de
france les ministres on peut lire 1 se
sont montrés particulièrement l écoute
des sénateurs merci quentin pour ce
retour d'information alexia germond on
vous l'avait un tout petit peu évoqué
tout à l'heure sur voilà ce que l'aller
les journées qu'on est en train de vivre
ce sont les prémices de ce que peuvent
être les prochaines semaines et sans
doute les prochains mois on verra
combien de temps dure ce ce gouvernement
est le rôle du sénat comment vous
l'imaginez se construire dans les
prochains mois il ya un rééquilibrage
enfin le rôle du sénat a toujours été
bien sûr bien sûr très important mais il
ya un vrai rééquilibrage qui est en
train de se faire on a d'abord eu je
crois un premier équilibrage apprécié
ces résultats c'est que le pouvoir qui
était auprès de l'exécutif a basculé
vers le législatif voilà et à
l'intérieur du législatif on voit bien
que justement les grandes figures qui
sont présentes qui ont vraiment
l'expérience du terrain qui ont été
amenés à gouverner par le passé
il y aura un prisme différent aussi du
sénat avec une vraie une vraie
responsabilité en tout cas quelque chose
qui sera très intéressant à regarder à
analyser c'est comment vont-ils
réconcilier entre les groupes par
exemple prenons le groupe ait l'air on
voit bien que au sénat donc il y à une
posture de responsabilité ine on en
attendait pas moins qui était qui et de
évidemment protéger les frontières
encadré apparition mais pourtant le
groupe ait l'air à l'assemblée a voté
contre alors est ce qu'il ya des
disciplines de vote qui vont se faire je
prends les nerfs là mais on pourrait
prendre d'autres d'autres groupes mais
je trouve qu'il y aura aussi du travail
à faire sur ce sujet là là la cohésion
de la cohésion et la convergence au sein
même notamment de la famille et leur
dernier thème de notre débat les
réactions après ses propos de la
ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités territoriales on écoute
caroline cayeux c'était sur l'antenne de
public sénat je ne pense pas avoir parlé
de caprice je trouve oui à l'époque je
maintiens évidemment mes propos mais
j'ai toujours dit que la loi si elle
était votée je l'appliquerais puis je
vais vous dire quand même que j'ai
beaucoup d'amis parmi tous ces gens là
et franchement c'est un mauvais procès
qu'on me fait et ça m'a beaucoup
contrarié mais vous comprenez c'est que
cette expression mais je n'ai jamais et
je n'ai jamais fait partie de la manif
pour tous jamais je n'ai jamais défilé
que les choses soient claires j'ai
beaucoup d'amis parmi ces gens là la
phrase elle est
désastreux cette impression de revenir
dix ou vingt ans en arrière car chartier
même si la ministre a reconnu des propos
inappropriés elle a rappelé que
l'égalité des droits reste une priorité
du gouvernement le mal est fait oui
alors c'est vrai que ça fait vraiment
penser à ces gens qui disent oh bah moi
les arabes je les aime beaucoup enfin
j'ai mon voisin qui a rappelé que je
suis pas raciste par ailleurs tiennent
des propos donc en effet c'est d'une
maladresse insigne je pense que le sujet
est assez compliquée en fait parce que
effectivement là l'expression contre
nature qui avait employé
qu'elle avait employé sénatrice
milliards en 2013 je crois renvoie très
funeste passé qui vichy qui avait
pénalisé l'homosexualité en disant que
c'était donc un comportement contre
nature donc ça nous ramène quand même
impasse est épouvantable donc ça c'est
certain
en même temps ça me fait quand même
pensé
vous allez trouver peut-être le
parallèle assez étrange mais le fait de
critiquer en l'espèce ses propos
critiques en 2013 le mariage pour tous
et qui critiquait pas l'homosexualité
entente elle donc
considéré que le mariage pour tous
c'était quelque chose contre nature
donc c'est un comportement mais elle ne
critiquait pas les individus
d'autres personnes qui sont pas
forcément des politiques mais je pense à
alain delon j'ai en souvenir alain delon
qui avait eu plusieurs fois dans des
interviews critique est effectivement
l'homosexualité en disant que c'était
contre nature
est ce que légalement je pose la
question mais je pense qu'elle doit être
posée est-ce que critiquer un
comportement équivaut à critiquer les
personnes qu'est ce que ça veut dire
forcément homophobie je pense que c'est
cette question que ça pose sur le fond
et deuxièmement encore une fois je n'ai
enfin soyons bien clairs c'est l'analyse
elle est subie je suis pas aussi
bons sons sont très problématiques mais
je reviens sur la déclaration total 2013
et puis j'ajouterai qu'il ya un autre
élément c'est que les associations qui
aujourd'hui donc
se dresse contre une plainte voilà une
plainte vise aussi d'autres ministres si
j'ai bien compris quand même qui eux ont
pris position contre le mariage pour
tous donc là aussi c'est finalement une
opinion savent qu'il n'est pas interdit
quand même d'être contre le mariage pour
tous c'est quand même verte et d'opinion
enfin on peut considérer qu
effectivement c'est pas bien tout
simplement donc je pense que l'afer est
très compliqué parce que effectivement
ya la thématique homophobie mais il ya
aussi une autre thématique qui se mène
là dedans du il à ceux qui pensent bien
il ya ceux qui pensent mal j'entends sa
voix y est surtout une thématique hyper
réac
frappe je n'appartiens la barbe des
manuels macron qu'ils voulaient mais
effacé le clivage droite-gauche établir
un clivage conservateur progressiste
orient moi je suis encore des
progressistes les autres cda fois
concerne la ldc réunion de ses ministres
mais d'ailleurs c'est intéressant je
vais je vous donner la parole juste
après mais je vous propose d'écouter
la réaction d'une collègue de caroline
cayeux puisqu'elle ministre de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes c'est
isabelle rome qui était cet après midi
au micro d'alexandre poussard
je pense que ce qui est contre nature
c'est le conservatisme voilà après voilà
la ministre s'est excusé ça me semble
important car il faut que la parole
publique soit très clair sur ce sujet ce
qui est très clair aussi c'est que le
gouvernement le président la république
la première mais nice moi même sommes
pleinement engagés pour les droits des
personnes lgbt pour l'égalité en droits
de toutes et tous et personnellement
j'ai déjà rencontré un bon nombre
d'associations qui est un militant
justement pour l'égalité en droits je me
suis rendu aussi dans un certain nombre
de centres qui accueillent de jeunes
personnes lgbt plus voilà je pense que
la mobilisation doit être totale et
notre soutien peut être aussi total ce
qui est contre nature c'est le
conservatisme c'est ça ce qu'il faut
retenir dans l'intervention d'isabelle
roche indienne olivier ce que ça peu
cette séquence ça peut laisser des
traces au sein du gouvernement bornes
wii au sein du gouvernement par louis
puis d'un combi d'opinion également je
trouve également intéressant c'est que
c'est un je dis pas que le sujet est
sorti de nulle part mais quasiment parce
qu'en fait c'est pas un sujet
d'actualité il n'y a pas aujourd'hui en
fait un des pneus il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui un débat pour savoir à quel
droit ou pas sont adonnés aux couples
homosexuels on n'a même pas aujourd'hui
un débat sur la pma la gpa ou tu vas
donc on est vraiment dans un bain dans
un aspect qui est peu hors contexte
d'opinion ou hors contexte législatif ou
encore contexte réglementaire et que on
se rappelle que catherine vautrin qui
était pressenti même un peu plus que
pressant 10 pour arriver à matignon si
elle n'a pas une des raisons pour
lesquelles elle n'est pas arrivée à
matignon c'est qu'il ya une rebuffade de
la part justement de proches des manuels
mâcon pour faire vite une partie de la
gauche qui s'est opposé au nom du fait
que l avait pris fait et cause contre le
mariage que le match pour tous et donc
ça montre bien que dans une société
française les dimensions de valeur et
sont fondamentales et qu'on l'ait pas
toujours dans un registre qui m
enregistre d'efficacité on va pas
toujours et on autorise de savoir est ce
que ça fonctionne nous savons pas
personne ne pose la question aujourd'hui
savoir est-ce que globalement il ya une
efficacité ou est ce que on a personnes
qui sont plus ou moins intégrés dans les
cités françaises terrain où est-ce
qu'elles sont créés une forme de
communauté à part donc c'est pas du tout
ce débat là c'est plus un débat de
valeur générale et qui vient toucher ou
percuté aujourd'hui ce débat global elle
est on va conclure avec vous n'allez
saint germain on pourrait parler d'une
expérience sauf que j'ai vérifié cet
après-midi caroline cayeux elle a pris
sa première carte d'adhérente au rpr
c'était en 1980 juste après la victoire
de françois mitterrand nokia s'est pas
c'est pas de l'inexpérience elle assume
ses propos et dans la droite ligne de ce
qu'elle disait avant il ya une dizaine
d'années elle assume ses propos il ya
une logique il ya une cohérence par
rapport au parcours mais vous parliez
d'une maladresse mais c'est aussi
peut-être mangé une autre réflexion
c'est
quand on est ministre il faut un vrai
sens politique et peut-être que madame
cayeux on a un peu moins que ce ce à
quoi on s'attendait
voilà malgré son expérience malgré son
expérience mais les ministres sais c'est
pas la même chose que d'être
mère d'une très grande ville aussi merci
beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat